yeah that's right and we've watched
these figures every day don't we to see
the way that the disease is behaving the
way that that trend is developing so as
you say there the number of people who
have been infected by covert 19-2 have
tested positive for that disease up to
40 1903 and as you said there as well
the total number of people who have
sadly lost their lives from this disease
4313 that's a jump of 708 from yesterday
that's the biggest daily jump we've seen
so far in the time that this disease has
been spreading around the UK but worth
saying it's not percentage-wise an
enormous jump it's worth of course
emphasizing that every person who dies
from this it is horrifying and behind
every statistic is a real person a real
family going through a horrific time but
over the past four days or so the
percentage increase between the numbers
at which these are increasing day on day
has been stabilizing a little so
although it is an increase it's not an
enormous one from what we saw yesterday
yesterday that number increased was 684
today 708 also revealed by the
Department for Health and Social Care
today was the number of tests that were
taken in the UK yesterday that was
10,000 984 up fractionally from the day
before on Friday they did 10,000 590 but
worth saying are you remember just this
week Matt Hancock the health secretary
said that they're hoping to do as much
as a hundred thousand a day by the end
of April so really a tenth of what that
target eventually is